[Music]
yeah was one of the worst and most
one-sided transactions the United States
has ever entered in the event we are not
able to reach a solution working with
Congress and our allies then the
agreement will be terminated
what is the what-if scenario or your
plan B but my point is to say don't
leave now the GCP way as long as you
have not a better option for nuclear
obviously this would be a very bad
precedent that if the United States
sends this message to the international
community that the length or the
duration of any agreement would depend
on the duration of the presidency well
talking about the Iran deal there and
that will be talked with between
President Trump and the French president
McCrone who arrived here in Washington
today also arriving at the White House
came in at Joint Base Andrews with his
wife there and then arrived at the White
House for talks with the president they
are currently the two couples together
at Mount Vernon in the historic George
Washington homestead having a dinner
tonight before the official state dinner
tomorrow what about this and foreign
policy news let's bring in our panel
Steve Hayes editor-in-chief of the
Weekly Standard Dan Balz national
political correspondent at Washington
Post and Charlie hurt opinion editor for
The Washington Times Dan it is a big
visit it's obviously the first state
visit official and what do you think
both sides are looking for out of this
visit well I think clearly president
McCrone has come on a mission to try to
talk the president into staying in the
Iran agreement the Europeans are very
much alarmed that the president could
pull out of this he's signaled that he's
likely to may 12th is the deadline in
which he's got either recertify the
agreement or decide to pull out of it we
know that the team that used to be
around him kept him from doing that we
don't know where the new team is going
to end up but McCrone is here to argue
that they are trying to work out some
arrangements and some agreements that
will satisfy the president's concerns
and keep him in it yeah and you think
that's possible Steve I think it's
possible look the the Trump
administration
been pushing a plan in bilateral
discussions with Great Britain Germany
and France seeking to stay in the deal
calling for additional snap inspections
of military sites additional snapback
sanctions something that would have a
bite with Iranian non-compliance in the
deal this has been under discussion for
six weeks maybe longer the question is
whether Germany will will agree to it
France has been pushing France in the
United States are in very similar
position on this stuff Great Britain is
think a little harder Germany has really
been difficult that I would imagine that
that President Trump and McCrone will
spend some time talking about how to get
Germany aboard this new plan
even if Russia has already declared that
they will won't be part of anything
other than the existing deal Charlie you
know I think it's kind of an interesting
situation McCrone has has I think is
working well with Donald Trump he's he's
figured out that if you kind of listen
carefully to what he says and sort of
ignore some of the unusual the the in
politics style things that Donald Trump
does that you can actually get somewhere
where that one of the things I admire
about about what Trump has done here is
obviously campaigned on the promise that
he was going to tear this thing up on
day one he hasn't yet that he was
prevented from it could talk out of
doing that but but yet again you're
looking at a situation where Donald
Trump has sort of multiplied the moving
parts whether it's with the tariffs
whether it's with you know the
negotiations in North Korea whatever you
have a lot of moving parts and when you
have a lot of moving parts there's a lot
more ways of sort of cutting the pie and
getting deals that satisfy everybody at
the table and and I imagine that is
probably what they'll be talking about
tonight at Mount Vernon you know about
the Iran deal now you as Steve mentioned
have a different group around him John
Bolton obviously opposed to the Iran
nuclear deal
Pompeyo is opposed to the Iran nuclear
deal I've pressed him on it numerous
times he said he finds zero beneficial
and now he is moving forward with this
nomination speak about that the fact
that there was this this political
process right during this show Chris
Coons voting present enables a favorable
recommendation from the committee on to
the floor where he will have the votes
to get through yes and and he you know
it's he will be the next Secretary of
State and he has the president's ear in
a way that secretary tiller said never
did he has he has earned a relationship
with the president through hours spent
doing the daily briefing and doing other
things he spent a considerable amount of
time with the president the president
obviously trusts him
I think one of the interesting things
there was there was a little
equivocation in his confirmation
hearings about the Iran deal which
suggested he may not be quite where he
was earlier on this and so I think that
it remains to be seen exactly how that
will come out but we know that he and
Bolton have been much more hostile to
this agreement than prior team while we
were talking we got the video in from
Mount Vernon of the French president and
the president meeting there they planted
a tree that president McCrone brought to
the White House and then they took a
helicopter ride marine one around the
monuments in Washington and then here
they are arriving at Mount Vernon and
they he's obviously giving a little
instructional about Mount Vernon there
to the French president and they will
have dinner together the two couples
before the big official dinner tomorrow
night Steve it is amazing to see the
relationship that has developed since
President Trump's visit to Paris yeah
you remember that handshake and and all
of the scuttlebutt that surrounded that
really interesting interview with
McCrone yesterday by chris wallace
making some news i think on a couple of
different fronts I think Charlie's right
the French president has taken the time
to listen to Donald Trump and to
understand how to play the president I
mean to appeal to the places where
President Trump needs appealing in much
the way some Republican lawmakers have
have done and he I think keeps his
criticism usually private doesn't go
around broadcasting it doesn't go around
taking shots at President Trump he's got
a difficult balance to strike if Donald
Trump is not popular in France he's not
popular in Western Europe generally so
he's got to be careful not to seem like
he's being a toady to president Trump
but at the same time or or boasting
about his success in persuading him on
Syria for instance well
the same time appealing to the president
me play the sound buy from Akron on
Syria talking to our own Chris Wallace
in Paris we will have to build the new
Syria after what the day we will have
finish this war against Isis if we live
definitely and totally even from a
political point of view we will leave
the floor to the Iranian regime Bashar
al-assad and these guys and they will
prepare as a new one so how much
influence he has over Trump foreign
policy I think that was I think that was
a mistake for him to say that because
they're talking about rebuilding Syria
you want to get people running for the
hills here that's the way you do it talk
about killing Isis and and destroying
Isis that's a lot more appealing but I
do think it's it's it's sort of a nice
moment to stop and reflect you have the
French president the American president
at Mount Vernon tonight and to think of
the truly amazing things that have
happened but to whether it's Rochambeau
and and and General Washington planning
for the the siege of Yorktown or the the
Marquis de Lafayette coming to visit
Washington during the war it's a pretty
neat thing to think about what's going
on on the banks of the Potomac right now
it really is